right thank you can surpass those words
of wisdom that would just affect to
start the meeting tonight deliberately
put it at this they couldn't see me it
might be an improvement
no thank you for turning up to tonight's
planning yeah it's a bit better
super thank you've come into tonight's
meeting I believe there might be a
football match on a bit lighter there's
a commentary city fun I don't know a lot
about football but I think we've got an
important game later I said before
somebody else did just can't remind
people to make sure their and their bar
phones are on silent or switched off and
can only the register speakers please
speak and no interruptions however
tempting it might be please not
interrupt the speakers thank you item on
the agenda which is apologies for
absence chen we've got apologies from
councillors O'Donnell Perry st. but I'd
also like to give apologies from
councillor Williams because he was being
a substitute unfortunately he's ill
today okay it's almost like a football
analogy but all these substitutes on him
but hopefully we won't be going into
extra time against their food in are you
with us are you okay okay spitting hello
John hi are you with us thank you
it's always loved it
go good yeah it's almost like being a
referee tonight isn't it yeah trying to
keep two teams under order under control
good okay right um disclosures of
interest have any members disclosures
ooh no co-sleeper and the minutes of the
meeting on the 20th of June
are you happy near the ice on those
super will just move on to item number
four which is application we've got two
two items on the agenda yeah thank you
obviously I've been told to Tran be as
prompt as possible and I'm remiss in my
duties that I haven't introduced the top
table
so on my right-hand side I'm buying some
committee services Jamie Parsons legal
planning manager in my role as an
impartial adviser to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the art epi
planning committee members are not bound
by the case officers recommendation
David Jeffrey team leader West Victoria
try to a Senior Planner thank you super
thanks that down just like to ask the
committee if they would be willing to
vote on moving the agenda around and
bring the forward application number six
which is 17 / 0 to 203 a few hour to the
next item on the agenda so I just
wondered if we could take a vote on that
please I was in private that we bring
this on forward
thank you right I will now move that on
so that's he's 43 just checking to do
another so that is don't speak on that
one check the recommendation to this
application has changed its now defer as
it's a matter that should be dealt with
by West Clemente not by this committee
thank you catch the Brian happy second
all those in favor
thank you committee is recommended that
we defer item 17 0 to 203 if you are
thank you very much we will now go back
to the agenda which is item number 4
bear witness
catch the vans just come on Tom we just
coming onto that one now go definitely
keen off never good no use the keys to
them I'm very impressed thank you when
they move on to item number four and the
agenda
number 17 / 0 3 0 100 M land off Warrick
Road cotton and yeah there is also an
amended recommendation for this item the
recommendation is to resolve to defer it
as the applicant has agreed to amend the
housing mix and to work further with the
parish council on their concerns catch
the brain cancer Kendall can we get a
vote on that
all those in favor unanimous chairman
thank you
so we'll now move on to item 5 on the
agenda which is application 17 / 0 3 7 8
2 fu ow
it will be Victoria cello eye Hill we've
presented this item Thank You Victoria
Thank You chair let me just make that
fullscreen for planning permission is
proposed for the demolition of the
dwelling known as Court closed and the
significant clearance of the associated
garden area and then the erection of ten
dwellings across the site including an
improved access to the site and a
publicly accessible green to be located
at the north of the site the site is
located off Mill Street countin as
indicated by the black dot here is a
site outlined in red the orange dot
indicates the existing dwelling at court
close this plan shows the siting context
of the surrounding area and you can see
that the plot of this site is
significantly larger than the grain of
the character surrounding it the pink
line shown here is the boundary of the
conservation area which circumnavigates
the site particular to the north west
and south but the site itself is not
within the conservation area and the
nearest listed building is to the north
of the site which is five Lodge this is
an existing plan of the site this is the
tree plan for the site court closes up
here the green trees indicated are those
to be retained those outlined are those
that are proposed to be removed as part
of this development the tree survey
submitted indicated that the majority of
these if not all of them were of a low
grade this is the 3d aerial perspective
of the proposed development this is Mill
Street to the north of the site coming
here onto salbon Street and this is
leading to the main village of Quinton
village Green is proposed to the north
of the site with the boundary wall to be
retained and a public access going
through the site leading on to sell them
Street the
includes a mixture of housing including
bungalows and two-story dwellings the
site has considered the general
character and layout of the area
bungalow proposed to the entrance of the
site adjacent where there's an existing
bungalow here the two-story properties
would frame the proposed green and lower
bungalows where they are more adjacent
to existing dwelling houses on the site
story surrounding the site for context
this is a plan view of the site so as
you can see how it relates to existing
properties more clearly again the
properties shown with rooves on of
proposed bungalows and those in plan
form are the two-story properties the
darker green circles are the proposed
additional planting albeit that that is
proposed to be conditioned by our
landscaping plan this is an extract from
the technical notes of highways
technical notes submitted with the
planning application this shows a
visibility display of the access of the
proposed site the existing property
would be demolished here enabling a
greater visibilities to play leading
into the site and this notes proposed
give way markings on Mill Street
appreciate this probably isn't that
clear to see I will show you these
photos in more detail in a second but
essentially this at the top is the
existing access to the site that's court
closed as fans this is within the
proposed site so in the middle looking
out in the center here is you tree which
is within the neighboring property
little quadrant this is view of the
properties to the rear of the site here
and this is Mill Street with its
boundary here this is Mill Street this
is the garage that curtilage building to
Fife lodge this is an existing bungalow
and this is where the first proposed
bungalow would be located this is Court
closed as existing this is Mill Street
leading on to South and Street here the
existing wall behind which their
proposed
Green would be located and this is from
the other angle of that same view this
is the access as looking at it from
Southland Street looking into Mill
Street Junction these are the existing
properties on Mill streets probably the
closest along that eastern boundary of
the site this is that panoramic photo
again you treat little quadrant which is
located here plot nine would be roughly
here these are at the southeastern
corner of the development and that's the
rear of Court close the existing
property on site at the end of my
presentation
GEB the there are updates to this scheme
which are provided in your update sheet
which include additional conditions in
relation to those within my report there
was a site visit today over which
yourself counts in the mills and
councillor fielding attended one and
yourself yep no further updates thank
you
recommendation is to approve Thank You
Victoria and it was certainly slightly
more overgrown today than it was so we
did well to avoid to stinging nettles
and brambles sir
so hold them and move on to us first
speaker which is cancel that in Davis
from Canton parish council
hi mr. Davis I've got three minutes
would you like a warning shot bow with
about 30 seconds to go
thank you see they're far away when
you're ready okay Thank You general good
evening counselors I'd be awful kind of
parish council we do object to this lot
of the development per se because this
site is appropriate for development
purposes but because of a lack of
consideration of the highway
implications as a consequence of this
development a little bit of background
the Canton neighborhood development plan
was very careful when it's proposed new
development in the village because of
the significance concerns and the number
one priority concerns the local
residents about traffic both in terms of
volume congestion parking issues and
occasionally speed and the development
was proposed on the western north of the
village this the the access forum or the
exit from this development goes on to
Southland Street and whichever way you
look at it there are two narrow single
carriageways going on to south and
street which is one of the busiest
streets through the village the village
has six roads converging on it from
different villages and Sultan Street
takes traffic out to the moon to a
Jaguar Land Rover Aston Martin very busy
and the the configuration of Southland
Street is not good because it's
traditional and historical in nature a
very narrow in parts and as a
consequence of that the use the current
use and the current problems are those
two single carriageways from this
development site onto something street
frequently leads to congestion because
cars are trying to travel both ways up
it and those coming off something street
frequently have to reverse back onto the
main road because cars can't get past
because there's single character is
either the one you've seen which is
bounded by two walls although all the
road that goes past the green where
there's parking by local residents
because they don't have any off street
parking so they park on the street
rendering it a single-camera
the parish councils representations to
the county councillors the highway
authority fallen on deaf use it doesn't
fit their model there isn't a traffic
problem in Kyneton whatsoever
much to local people's annoyance because
we know there is because we see the
pinch points and this is south and
Street is one of those pinch points so
if you are minded to grant this the
parish council has requested the traffic
management plan to deal with the
consequences of exacerbating the current
problems arising from this development
we believe there are some simple
solutions here in terms of a traffic
management plan is it's up to engineers
to provide those solutions not ourselves
but we believe the highway implications
because of these local circumstances
which are I fully understood thank you
which are not fully understood and
appreciated but the County Council has
the high rail authority need to be
reflected in a traffic management plan
and I would urge the committee if you're
minded to approve this you have you you
condition it along those lines and
hopefully that will help resolve some of
the current issues as well as avoiding
exacerbating those issues through this
development thank you and it was quite
busy then is it throughout the day or is
it peak times or pinch points regarding
the traffic flows there are peak times
particularly morning and afternoon as
there are in any villages or any urban
areas so but but the the the the two-way
traffic on these single carriageways can
happen at any time and the reversing on
the southern road can happen at any time
but it's mostly in the mornings over an
hour period and in the afternoons trim
thank you very much sir quiver next
speakers please and it's mr. Hughes mr.
Berluti
[Music]
oh sorry yes
basic technology we've got three mix
between you ie is one speaking and one
never questions my intention thank you
far away bear begin I am obviously the
little quadrant which is a parentless
discussion already of the property
surrounding the court closed development
mine is the most exposed the development
of busts the whole of my western and
southern boundary fences over the
distance of some 34 metres in January I
formerly objected to that part of the
development that directly affected my
immunity a type a building of the
southern boundary of my property on plot
9 which would overshadow my garden and
the positioning of a car park and refuse
handling area the western boundary which
would degrade courtesy and undoubtedly
generate noise adjustments were made to
the car parking area and the lobby is a
key area removed and with that I am
content the gable end of a type a
high-status to run for 6 meters along my
southern boundary remains it diverges
the slight angle from the start point
only one point four meters south of my
southwest corner post it blocked light
into a large part of my garden
particularly winter now a recent
amendment would have stated that the
gable end was now half hip I'm not quite
sure what that means but it will I think
it's a slight slope in the roof light
levels of the garden one proves a
marginal degree the impact of a four to
five meter high red brick wall six
meters in length remains no other home
on the periphery of the development is
so impactful simony of a building the
salt gable end fully visible from the
full-length windows of our southern
facing day area and casting a shadow
across the garden will serve to degrade
our room and garden amenity the planning
statement para eight-to-one states that
care has been taken during the design
process to ensure there'll be no
to the immunity of surroundings resident
and that the occupiers are so glad
reasons and that the occupiers of the
proposed dwellings will have a high
level of immunity I am certain of the
second part stands gate planning has
never spoken or talked to me about the
first part
my objection remains but I would be
better left so you have two minutes so
you want to fight between you for the
rest of the hour you attention to these
photographs which were taken over the
last sort of four five month period the
focusing question highlight a number of
inaccuracies that have been flagged up
the lack of parking control on the
street currently means that cars can
park on either side there's no mention
of the village hall which is in within
50 metres of the entrance to this site
which is one of the busiest amenities in
the village and the number of vehicles
parking on on this on the pavements
forces both children and buggies to go
into the road to access it and this
particular incident here is where
parking on the corner of the axis on
South and Road creates blind spot for
vehicles accessing Mill Street and I
echo David Douglass's objections in
regard to the repositioning of the
bungalow as well I'll take on the visual
display issue the retaining wall that's
evidenced in the in the photographs the
idea to drop that down to sixty
centimetres is a bit of a laugh when
obviously the car is the same height as
the walls that will be arguably reduced
in height to create the visible physical
visual splays
No thank you very much and thank you
very much for that's me through to look
at mr. Doherty so thank you right well
now move on to our next speakers which
miranda Rogers and Dave Neal obviously
you've got six minutes between you but
I'll be split or this one it will be
split and are you one-to-one after three
minutes or good evening quart close is
an unusual property as you've seen it
comprises a large rather unattractive
dwelling situated immediately the back
of the highway behind what is behind
which is hidden a substantial unused
garden it's located in the heart of
crimson but you'd hardly know it was
there it's exactly the kind of windfall
site that the policies of the core
strategy and the clinton neighborhood
plans supporting coming forward for
redevelopment court closed was bought by
built by and for the coles family in the
1930s Mary Cole's the last resident died
in 2015 and the house has remained
vacant ever since none of her 10 that
nephews and nieces were able to move
into the house and instead decided to
modestly develop the site in a way to
create a legacy for the village and
contribute to the local community early
contact with the parish council
suggested a car park open space
bungalows and family housing the car
park was discounted as the council did
not have the funds to purchase or run it
so that proposal before you provides a
public open space a green space at the
front of the site containing a new
footpath to create a safe link between
the village center and the village hall
which does not currently exist a total
of ten dwellings five bungalows and five
houses are proposed rather than applying
for outline permission this is a
detailed application alongside with the
covenant which will ensure the bungalows
are built and not exchanged for larger
units when the site is sold to the
developer in this way the needs of the
local community can genuinely be met and
the legacy left
a consultation event was held to discuss
the proposals and many of the immediate
neighbors received a visit from the
applicant the overwhelming response was
one of support the key issue which arose
was highways but also neighbor amenity
loss of wildlife habitat and the
potential impact of any loss of trees on
local heritage assets my colleague here
is going to discuss highways matters in
a moment but looking at the other issues
neighbor amenity there has only been one
objection to the application regarding
neighbor amenity for mr. Daugherty who
you heard from earlier his property is
close to proposed plot nine although the
proposal met already met the council
standards the scheme has twice been
amended to alleviate any perceived
adverse impact it's concluded by your
officers to be entirely acceptable trees
there are no high-value trees within the
site but none of the better ones are to
be lost and the new trees are proposed
as part of the scheme all the trees
along Mill Street frontage air to be
retained and a detailed landscaping plan
will be agreed in accordance with
proposed conditions as a result there's
no home to live by heritage assets in
fact the removal of court closed itself
and the opening up of the side entrance
when enhance the conservation area an
ecology the layout includes open space
which provides some ecological benefits
and bat mitigation measures are also
proposed to offset any overall financial
loss so any overall loss a financial
contribution is to be made through a
section 106 agreement there has been no
adverse comment about the overall design
or the layout and setting aside highways
for a moment proposal accords with the
policies of the development plan Thank
You Miranda and good evening councillors
I'm Dave Neal and I work for David took
her associates transport planners based
in Hanlon Arden I've been advising on
this project since its conception
incidentally I'm also a resident of
coins in a no location well I drove a
drive through the Mill Street South and
Street Junction on a daily basis I also
walk past the site regularly to from the
shops with my two young children
initially I set out in the officers
report watch county councillors local
Highway Authority requested an
independent safety audit was
commissioned to consider the site access
arrangements the subsequent comments
were all in relation to the site layouts
and not regarding the Princip
or wider impacts of the development the
safety audit raised two minds both of
which have been addressed
therefore all matters relating highway
impact and the layout have been resolved
to the satisfaction of the highway
Authority and your planning officer
notwithstanding this and informative her
tonight I understand you know there's
local concern regarding the site
particularly regarding the operation of
the middle streets Alvin Street Johnson
as a robust assumption the development
could generate nine to ten vehicles in
the pika which is on average one every
six minutes and this would be generally
generally imperceptible cars park either
side of the junction on Southam street
which i think you've seen on the photos
which requires vehicles to edge out at
times vehicles are required to wait on
south and street while a vehicle leaves
Mill Street however due to the low speed
of traffic due in part to the park cars
this is not caused any road safety
issues this is also supported by the
lack of recorded collisions
there'll be clear benefits as a result
of the development the removal of the
existing court closed building from the
edge of the carriageway will assist with
the neighboring vehicles to pass at the
new creek newly created entrance and
we'll open up the for divisibility along
the line furthermore the development
proposes a new footpath within the wall
that will connect the existing footway
to the east of the site to the foot way
on Southam street
this will provide a traffic-free route
for pedestrians also accessing the
community library finally its proposed
to condition a construction management
plan to be submitted prior to
commencement of the development this
will assist with ensuring vehicles use
prescribed routes at times of the day to
reduce the impact on the local community
this would be in consultation with the
highway authority and the Parish Council
many thanks for your time on them take
any questions
sorry my apologies there are no
guarantees on the site there are okay so
if have you looked with regards to the
council's policy on parking per property
the current policy which requires lots
of parking spaces parking spaces and the
layout was amended through the course of
the application once those standards
were published in March we've got not
only one so two or three parking spaces
per dwelling depending on the size of
the dwelling but also I think it's
placed 37th over too many pages counts
the barns have unit it does appear that
you have had consultation with the
parish council because of the planning
game have you had any consultation in
the respect to this highway problem that
appears to be the main stumbling block
consultation with the Parish Council I
think I've been to see them four times
during the course before you during the
course of the application they refrained
from giving any detailed response until
the application had already been
submitted and in fact the first time we
knew they were like they were going to
object was on the day we went approach
council meeting and we took on we saw a
very brief comment
they've refrained from making a detailed
comment until after the safety audit was
carried out and after the safety audit
was carried out and my colleague here
did a detailed technical response which
covered their comments as well as I've
got once more question you mentioned in
your presentation you'd carried out some
consultation which indicated support for
this publication was any evidence of
this provided to the case officer to
demonstrate this because I can't see
anything in the report involvement which
set out what consultation had taken
place
they had copies of the board's it had
copies of the questionnaire that was
responded in it had details responses to
the points raised in that consultation
event and our how we altered the scheme
in accordance with that there was a full
document that should have been on the
council as well just following on fill
up but none of people who indicated
their support at that consultation have
entered Britain in independently no okay
thank you and this is not uncommon
because generally that's why you answer
the question that's fine thank you right
thank you very much no more questions
and we'll now move on to our next
speaker
geez catch the Mill's
Oh cat smells how you thank you this
chair I'm fine
five minutes I shan't take five minutes
out boys well good evening committee my
objection to this application is
threefold
access the proposed site access to the
site for construction traffic and the
overbearing nature of the development on
neighboring residential properties
especially little quadrants in Mill
Street as you can see by the photo
showing the lanes in around the proposed
developments i extremely narrow
you've also switch we have also seen by
previous photos there is the safety
aspect to this application as the access
only I will only add to the way to
severe traffic problem along Mill Street
with traffic coming along from
Selvam Street which sleep top of that
lame there the lane our proposed site is
extremely narrow with no footpath and is
just for point one meters wide coming
out and entering the proposed site will
be very difficult even though the
original house would have been
demolished trying to create a better
access there will be two more dwellings
which could lead twenty to twenty more
cars going in and out of the development
throughout the course of the day which
route they would take is also
problematic problematic as it will be
very difficult to turn left out of the
site to access Selvam street that's if
you want to go to wells born or warwick
and and if they term right or they have
to renegotiate Mill Street and some
Peters Road which also have massive
parking issues you have seen firsthand
and this afternoon
how Castparts abili restricts the road
with my photos were taken very early in
the morning and throughout the day the
cars parked along they are from the
businesses within within the village and
would say we do have this big problem
the construction traffic will also bring
his own problems that the roads leading
to the proposed
are normally full of parked cars try
trucks trying to negotiate the junction
of mill streets and we will aim would
have terrible problems due to the parked
cars we also which has been mentioned
before have a very busy British Hall
which also leads to parking problems up
along North Street the construction of
the proposed sites may take a year
bringing with it the misery to the
residents of middle lane and Mill Street
how were the construction traffic into
the site even as the waste disposals
they have to back up back up Mill Lane
to reach the properties we also seen by
previous photos how problematic the
parking issue is this narrow lane is
also used as rat run for motorists who
use it to avoid going through the
village in essence a very busy little
lane you see the people from will come
down Blandy Road and turn right up your
lane cut round to avoid going through
the the village which is a nightmare in
the morning in summary the committee
will have seen a problems which the
development will cause not only to the
residents are joining the proposed
developments but also the massive
disruption caused by traffic to the area
while construction takes place if
Pickers believe that they've want
mortgage account cows or highways don't
seem to see these problems going on to
little quadrants and the proposed
bungalow this bungalow will cast a
shadow over the gardens which the
residents of little cotton were had to
ensure through this summer and winter
months I did have a diagram showing the
that proposed shadows casting summer and
Windsor but I was told there in
inaccurate to conclude just put yourself
in the shoes of the residents of little
quadrant whose lives will be severely
affected they have lived happily in the
house for 17 years only to have their
lives potentially obliged by this
development the psychological effect
could be devastating as I said this as
its narrowest point the bungalow is just
1.4 metres from the bottom of their
garden
I urge the committee not to grant this
vacation Thank You cats the bonds it it
wasn't in the neighbor plan no cast
accountant
I know you've got concerns in three
areas the parish council mention that
they might look more favorably on this
application if there was a traffic
management plan do you have any views on
that I understand this is just a traffic
on the trip we do need a traffic
management plan that's for sure which
would help but as I say my main issue
really is the the overbearing nature of
one of the properties and if this could
be moved well I say this this lane is as
you see unbelievably narrow we have a
lot of cars going up the lane cars
coming down the lane from south and
street they offer meet in the middle and
someone has to back up as a previous
speaker said they'd back up on to
Southam Street I can only see the people
coming out of that development will be
crazy to try and turn immediate left
because of this narrow lane
it was just okay the entrance will be
larger but the problem will still be
there even the they the lane opposite
where that door is
yes that laying there it'd be very hard
to find it to negotiate that because
cars are usually parked there during the
day not that particular part but just
further up outside the houses making it
one way so all in all extremely
difficult to make access to this site
and as I said if you look around the
from there
Mill Street and Mill Lane construction
traffic coming up into the site it's
going to be a nightmare fall and for the
residents mainly the residents right no
further questions Thank You cats the
mouse
Thank You mr. chairman points of
clarification for Victoria or diam any
new points that convocation come back to
this potential of traffic management
plan is there well Dale I suppose a
question for you maybe I don't know but
is this something you're aware of and
have you had some time to think about
what might be offered in this case
there's no indication in the response
that we've received from the local
Highway Authority and I've heard a
number of problems from the speakers I
haven't heard any clear indication of
where they need the traffic plan to take
us the problems are all existing
problems they're not problems that this
development will bring for this
development existing problems indicate
you or in the respect of the answer just
given is it any good that or can we put
a note on that the village or the parish
and the developers to come together with
it because you're saying we can't have
one we could perhaps the best place to
start that answer cherries to say I'm
absolutely not telling you that you
can't have one if you feel that there's
a benefit from a traffic management plan
and you've got some idea what it's
trying to achieve it would be entirely
appropriate to impose a condition but we
can only achieve what we can achieve
that's really all I can say I think I
would just add to that obviously
conditions need to be reasonable
justifiable and enforceable and a
traffic management plan it in a
commercial sense where it's sort of
perhaps a superstore something like this
where you're directing where staff would
park and I could see how that's
enforceable and how that works on in a
residential situation where people have
their own cars to park and have to leave
at certain time
today I'm I I would find it difficult to
understand how we could apply the test
for a condition under those
circumstances Jeff I can just assist I
mean I think it is clear what's been
said is that it is an existing problem
and as you'll be aware as a committee in
terms of conditions of 106 it is only
the mitigation leagues of the
development proposed that can be sought
to be mitigated if there are existing
problems that require a different
solution the planning permission before
you isn't the way to solve that it is
more a matter for them to make
representations to the counties the
highways or as the highway authority the
only thing I would say is that obviously
the Highway Authority has a statute
console t have made their response is
clear and there's not been a suggestion
that they would ask for even a traffic
regulation order in relation to W other
lines or anything due to the impact of
this development and I'm not saying
there are not traffic issues because I
think we all accept that there are
pretty much everywhere now
but that's the consultation response
we've had I just asked a question to you
Jamie um if we set a condition that can
be perceived as unreasonable how is that
challenged well obviously be mindful to
take advice that you are proposing if
condition2 neither you did suggest such
working so we consider at the forest
place on the planning permission but it
is a matter for you there's several ways
that they could challenge it one that
they could seek to appeal their decision
or JRA on the basis that you've taken
into consideration Norma Tyrael aspects
but it's more likely as a practical firm
they would probably submit a section 73
application to remove the condition
because it's not
necessary or enforceable potentially I
mean there's probably almost all the
grounds that it may not be applied
really depends on the wording
and as the planning officers have have
noted its the difficulty in both what
you're seeking to achieve and be able to
make sure that that's clearly expressed
and the enforceability when one looks at
traffic management plan and I would echo
my colleagues comments that they are
suitable for commercial entities whereby
you can put restrictions and controls on
the operator as to number plates and
everything like that so you can see
where the traffic is coming from and
everything in this instance I again
would active the points I struggle to
see how you will implement that and they
enforce it to be honest
thank you guys that's quite clear any
more points of clarification just just
one more this is probably so I can
understand the light lay out a bit more
could you put the site plan up again on
this and just have a look at where
little quadrant is in relation to the
proposed houses that are supposed to be
so nearby which one is little cautious
little quadrant here okay this is plot
nine the closest proposed to a lane with
a hip roof here and this is the main
garden area to the property to the
typical quadrant and at the top end of
that they're sincere building that's
attached as well so if you if you have
ended up winning and I mean next one
sorry two more up is that that's an
existing building on the corner on the
corner is that that's a bungalow that
not the closest one to a proposed I
guess it is that side to side view
between that yeah so that's them that
their garage is adjacent to the boundary
let's this is the proposed unglue
adjacent to that yes thank you
so I am correct in saying that we could
put a condition on or a note on we did
up as a bedford school and we've done in
Welford where deliveries are between
9:30 and 4 correct yes that can be
confusion
did you indicate wash your way to know
our last question mr. Doherty mentioned
the half hip a hip troof are shown in
implant form there i can go into the the
original file if you'd like to to show
that the hip in elevation but I haven't
got it on my presentation at this time
can I suggest that the so you can see it
here so if you look at the properties
shown there chair you'll see that they
are all gabled buildings every single
one of them with the exception of that
one there where the gable has been
removed as part of the negotiations in
order to reduce the impact on little
quadrant and I suspect that that may be
the the concern over half hip is is not
actually that it's a half hip is there
he put one side and a gable at the other
so half of the building is hint okay
thank you miss fielding do you have a
plan or photograph showing the yew tree
in the quadrants garden because that
does take up what I would have thought
this is the only photo I've got of the
year which is in the center this is the
panoramic obviously it's a bit skewed in
how the photos been taken I didn't take
a photo whilst I was on site today or
from the property itself but obviously
that does cast a shadow over the garden
itself but as designed by the occupier
of that dwelling themselves
what thank you I think we've clarified a
lot of points there so it could be move
on to the debate whose cancer bonds I
hear all the concerned about our way and
I can't say like usual because there is
a cancer counselor here but if there
isn't any major accidents or somebody
killed they don't do anything so that's
why I asked the question in respective
deliveries between 9:30 and four o'clock
which we have had on different sites
particularly at Biddeford school and in
WellPoint where they walk past the site
I really can't see how we can oppose it
on the concerns of the ward member and
the parish council in the respective
highways so as far as I'm concerned
there's a reasonable mix it's not too
dense has obviously been a lot of
thought gone into the fact that the fact
they have worked by the parish council I
think lady said four times in respect
getting the right buildings it's just if
you like not the right side but
unfortunately in my personal opinion we
can't I can't find a reason for refusal
for the concern of the locals so I'm
probably not happy but we'd like to
propose it with the conditions of
deliveries that I have spoken about
earlier case the feeling the parish
counselor did say that to say he wasn't
unhappy with the development only the
highways was the problem that he saw
it's going to be a problem wherever
whatever you try and do on that site but
with the demolition of that property at
the entrance wider entrance could be
made initially and also is going to be a
foot past in the future that runs
through the the green area that's going
to be developed on the site so it is
going to make it a bit safer for
pedestrians because that gap or that
roadway at the moment going up
road is narrow and if you got
pedestrians on it it's tight but you
know the long term it's going to be a
benefit in my view there's the candle
yes thank you Jim just to echo I think
what previous speakers have said I mean
I understand that it's not a popular
choice but that's right the entire
presentation I've been wracking my brain
so I cut with a whole reason to object I
can't find anything I'm sound planning
ground so based on that I'm happy to
second counselor Barnes proposition so
edges point of clarification
he just confirmed that that's in
relation with the additional condition I
set out and the additional benefit or is
it to amend construction yeah point
eight isn't it construction management
I'm sorry all the sons just so that's on
record yeah what I'm happy with that
council bonds yeah
councillor Barnes all it is is on the
update sheet there's a further request
is that okay yep thank you see you pal
okay or we've had a proposal on a second
I would just be following what my
colleagues have said
yeah we're just cash the bonds we got in
the delivery in construction traffic
plan management plan are you happy for
that to be delegated to officers to
decide or are you proposing a certain
time I'm quite happy for the officers to
do what we have done before is it does
appear that these builders know where
every lorry is coming at different times
you know satellite or whatever you like
to call it and we have found that
between 9:30 and 4:00 o'clock as work
extremely well we have one site in
Welford where we have asked them to
bring most of the materials in the
summer holiday by the school so as far
as I'm concerned I need those words in
but I'm quite happy for the officer
officers to put it more professionally
yeah the other thing is what obviously
I've got one of my Ward's tabernae
contention at the moment regarding the
weekends and bank holidays I can't
remember which if they don't work Friday
they can work Sunday believe it - yep
super we've had a proposal in a second
we go to the vote now all those in favor
you're not a mr. chairman thank you
Thank You Victoria they move to the next
item on the agenda which is application
number 18 slash zero zero nine eight
nine ful the Dutch barn and dance fit
ships announced on
conversion of agricultural building to
single residential drilling and change
of use of agricultural land to
residential curtilage and and our
speakers James are are you ready for
this right Vance okay should we James
but if you're happy so far away
Thank You chair and yes so as denoted by
the e sorry as noted by the black dots
the application site is located to the
east of darling Scott this plan shows
the relationship a little more clearly
with this site outlined in red and this
is the conservation area boundary off
Donna and Scott there so the application
seeks permission for the conversion of
an agricultural building to a dwelling
and the Associated change of the use of
land to residential curtilage is a bit
more has gotten bit more of a complex
history which will be revealed
throughout the presentation here's the
aerial photography just for context and
the official location plan so this here
demonstrates the elevations of the barn
in 2014 prior to any application on the
site for prior notification and these to
show the photos at that time as well so
in 2015 a prior approval was granted for
the change of use of the barn to a
single-story dwelling this slide here
shows the elevations of that prior
approval and this shows the The
Associated floor plan subsequently
following that permission works have
commenced and introduced additional
floor and a new internal steel work less
well therefore this slide here just
shows the elevations as existing as
currently on site and I also have a
photograph to demonstrate that at
present
so this application seeks full
permission to convert the barn to a
two-story dwelling these are the floor
proposed floor plans here as you can see
ground floor and first of all and the
new proposed elevations and pulling it
all together this shows the site plan
finally I've just got an image that
compares the original barn and the
existing structure highlights in the
original steels which are here the
uprights are still in place and the new
steel framework as well chair the
recommendation is to refuse the
application for the reasons outlined in
pages 73 and 74 of the committee report
a number of updates have been received
and they have been added to the update
sheet thank you thank you James move on
to our first speaker which is catch the
new broom from Edgington parish council
minutes I have come tonight to make you
aware of the level of the local support
for this application that level of
support is unusual for a planning
application as a parish council for
darkness Kurt I am aware of that support
it is also evident from the letters that
have been sent to the council and from
the petition that has been sent in there
have been no voices raised in opposition
to it darkness good is a small community
and one that is looking forward to
welcoming Robert Heath and his young
family this family needs a home and
whatever the technical issues are that
have stopped the work for many months
they should be allowed to finish the job
they have started the big metal frame
the
stands by the road is a constant
reminder to us all that there is a
frustrated local family who want to join
our community and who would want to join
our community thank you case the Barnes
thank you Zuma is just a rural community
is it yeah you know I mean we haven't
got a village we've got a church yeah
and not about org left okay we need more
people thanks very much thank you
all right we'll move on to our next
speakers which Robin Ursula Heath and
Natasha blackboard the silver hopeful of
connects up Natasha
correctly
safe they're numbers that's what I say
right you've got three minutes between
here and if you could stay seated
afterwards for any questions okay so
good evening I would like to introduce
Robert and Ursula Heath the applicants
to explain a little about themselves and
the importance of this application
in 2014 I persuaded my wife and family
to move back to this area from Cheshire
so that I could become a partner in that
my family's farm which involves three
generation and farms land in the local
area and employs a reasonable number of
local staff we are active members of the
local community and have been humbled by
the support given by the community
including letters of support from
several residents the parish council and
even a local petition supporting the
scheme we also received the support
councillor Saint prior to his
regrettable illness the plan was to
convert the barn into a permanent home
for me and my family we have rented in
ship's tent and in Stratford for the
last four years and still don't have a
permanent family home having obtained
consent in 2014 but I think I was 15 for
our home we were served a temporary stop
notice by the council in 2017 we stopped
at that point and have not restarted I
sought legal advice on the works we've
completed which was they did not require
planning permission this was later
confirmed by revisions to the paragraph
105 of the ppg yet the officer still
said the works are unauthorised the
consent will expire later this month
leaving no lawful me to complete the
conversion the application seeks to
regular eyes the planning position to
enable us to continue and fulfill my
promise to the family we invested time
energy a very large sum of money to the
work and legal costs after four years
were desperate to have a permanent home
and possible ability of several more
years with the possibility of several
more years whilst the planning situation
is resolved for us due to the
circumstances of the case my clients
left with no lawful means of completing
the dwelling for which permission was
already granted it is our opinion that
works were carried out lawfully if this
was in doubt previously it has now been
clarified by updates updates
105 which explicitly supports the
applicant this application complies with
all other provisions of class Q and the
officer himself considers the dwelling
to be of an appropriate scale and design
which was successfully integrate with
the site surroundings
there have been no objections from
statutory consul trees or neighbors the
officer is recommending refusal on the
basis that it will create a new isolated
dwelling in the open countryside
notwithstanding the existing approval in
place for a dwelling there is a vast
amount of policy justification for such
an approval a recent appeal ruling
clarified the definition of isolated
dwellings as physically separate or
remote from a settlement however this
dwelling is in with within walking
distance of darling skirt less than a
two-minute walk 30 seconds a dwelling in
this location is already included in the
council's housing commitment if this
consent is not permitted another house
is required elsewhere in the district to
compensate taken on its own merits this
application is policy compliant my
clients have complied with everything
asked of them by the council at every
stage and have been left in an
unenviable position this evening is the
last opportunity to seize the pragmatic
solution of allowing permission for a
scheme which already has content consent
but has been prevented from being
completed we're happy to answer any
questions you may have
shall I start first time for change and
could you mention you mentioned
paragraph 105 of regarding the legal
position could you just give me a bit
more clarification about that cuz I
didn't quite actually hear what you said
oh sorry
paragraph 105 of the PPG basically was
clarification that internal works in a
class you are not permitted but are not
prohibited by class Q so internal floors
and anything that doesn't affect the
external structure which has been mean
has been retained and not development
and therefore can be done under the
original consent which we got the stop
notice on just to make sure
see if it kasib and then catch the prime
am i right in thinking that I'm not sure
whether they would community from ships
and all that but this is a farm so
therefore if we approved this you
wouldn't have to commute am i right
that's correct
I wouldn't need to commute because I
would be within the Dukan of the
boundaries of my farm one of the farms
where my parents live is in darkness
scope which is where the animals are
kept so I'm within half a mile of my
parents farm the main farm which since
I've come back to Cheshire which is
where I run the farm from his in
Blackwell so that's under a mile away it
puts me right the hub of the family
business
the other question it's not good with
systems and that was a problem with IKEA
me which I didn't understand on the
past counselor sites cancel bonds will
clarify that in the points of
clarification from this well it's
cancerous ain't siaps cancer st. was
having problems yeah
so we'll clarify that in a minute any
any other questions for the applicant in
the agents tents the filled in to
indicate there no or you just wave in to
me yeah it's gonna be a farm house or is
it going to be a private dwelling is it
going to be tied in to the farm there is
not a condition at the moment that we're
aware of that's been put forward for it
to be tied to the farm but it is for the
people who run the farm is that it's a
private dwelling but it will be attached
to the farm can I just ask why you
didn't you didn't actually go go through
the rural workers or local needs
application but we did have this
conversation
with the enforcement officer at the time
and he advised us that he didn't think
there was any position for me applying
for a local work because we didn't have
buildings on the site with animals
because it was outside the existing and
I should be seeking for something that's
actually where the animals are but
obviously that's where my parents live
and they don't want to move from there
but I need to be there to support them
in terms of we would have been happy to
go that route with a condition on there
because it is for my family it is for me
to live there for that you know it's a
forever home right in the hub of the
farm and that wouldn't have been a
problem and we would have considered
that okay thank you
no gentlemen you okay over there yep any
further questions
No thank you very much thank you we
haven't got a ward member obviously his
comments were in the update sheet so
we're gone to the points of
clarification and loss clarify your
point counts the barns as well put your
microphone microphone please didn't
really count aside he's still yeah
that's right that's why he's not
available tonight another points of
clarification well if we were to approve
the application what a man you know the
conditions because we only saw an
outline of what it might look like to
understand my
well what I'm saying is this isn't the
full application with materials yes it
is submitted if I just scope go back to
the yes yeah they are listed and they
were in there actually with Indian
within the report and I've suggested
that the materials are acceptable I
think if we if you were minded to
approve that I would go along with the
condition somewhere along the lines of
materials to be as shown on the
submitted plants that might be for
Jeremy mock mr. Dale the applicant in
the agent mentioned para 105 under the
PPG but there's some clarification of
internal Wars not being prohibited on
the original consent if I'm reading that
correctly so there has been a change in
paragraph 105 of the and PPG that that
is correct it does say that internal
works are not generally development and
his diocese those reread for baton the
issue that we've we've got is obviously
the original class Q application was
determined under was determined in 2015
in accordance with those plans it's not
been constructed in accordance with
those plans when the PPG was when didn't
allow structure element searches such as
the first law so the change came prior
prior to the change the PPG if I may
just to just wait a little bit the
decision was made under the rules as
they applied on the day the decision was
made the rules have changed subsequently
and the rules would apply to any new
application made subsequently but they
don't apply retrospectively that's the
advice we're giving to you yeah thanks
that's pretty clear thank you are we
okay gentlemen any other points of
clarification
you okay cancer bonds far that concerned
it looks to me as though the family are
actually going to
sustainable is this appointed
clarification or we're going into the
debate I'm sorry no okay shall we move
on to the debate oh sorry I can't ask
you you can't speak um no no you can't
tell me afraid sorry catch the brain
okay it looks to me as though this
family are going to be sustainable in
this new development in the respect
instead of coming from I'm not sure with
its rapid or ships and all but the race
if you read lots of support from the
village
there's no objections whatsoever which
is a bit surprising really because
usually somebody wants to object as far
as I'm concerned I'm sorry that counts
the scientists adhere to believe support
or not support but that's the sort of
thing that he would do and far as I'm
concerned them on part happy to propose
this application with the conditions
that I want the development I think this
is a sustainable situation both the
animals the farmer and the farm and we
have support from the parish council the
government's are Bailey and I suppose
slightly a little bit more all the time
for agricultural buildings we did have a
bit of a problem with B Q at once on
whether the walls were high enough or
not high enough but it's true on my
patch have gone through on appeal so as
far as I'm concerned I would be happy to
propose the development to oppose
approval for this development catch the
brain
you know I know the area I don't know
the story it's not effective in my
opinion it was sustainable from
everything will come to clean conditions
in a bit mr. Parsons but you'd like to
clarify the point can we can I just
clarify um it would just assist in
relation to obviously the proposals for
refusal and that's fine it's a matter of
Fiat for you as the committee to
determine the applications you see fit
but from what your the comments made can
I just clarify that it would appear to
be that what you're saying is in effect
the full-back position through the park
you that although is being it's still in
existence but a certificate of
lawfulness failed before the the
council's planning department but what
you're basically saying is because there
was a park you permission that you'd see
that that is a material consideration in
granting this application yes yeah
that's great thank you just it's
obviously just nowadays what you have to
do is give reasons for your decisions
and I just wanted to clarify that that
was the rationale behind your planning
consideration
thank you yes so Joe would you liked
sorry James yeah I've got some
conditions and prepared the pretty
standardized so time limits approved
plans highways on their comments
recommended three conditions these were
servicing of the access with a bowel
material for seven point five meters
gates not being hung with some within
seven point five meters of the near edge
of the carriageway provision of a
turning area pretty standardized
conditions they're also asked under
conditions such as bin storage
electrical vehicle charging point hard
and soft landscaping details including
materials of boundary treatments
materials as I mentioned earlier as
shown on the approved plans and as part
of the application form and also we
would seek to remove the PD rights part
1 plus a 2 G inclusive part 2 Class A to
B this is just based on the fact that it
is a war bond and normally for classic u
permissions quite tightly constrained on
in that regard with regards to your
point about counts of buildings point
about agricultural or all workers
tie that wouldn't be a condition on this
instance it's not been applied for on
that basis it is an open market body
thank you yes so the materials would be
are shown on the plans they're very
similar to what's been approved
previously so we don't as officers don't
have a problem with the materials I say
it's a modernistic look but it's been
accepted previously thank you that's the
boss did you indicator stone
oh we're just going to say that we can't
have agricultural or tourism ties unless
the application is come up that you know
we used to be able to but we can't today
yeah that's yeah but that's correct its
market on it right I think
ism other materials in keeping with the
area as I said the materials are very
similar to what was already been allowed
via the original approval and condition
it's a boarding and the materials are
listed it is a boarding it will have a
modern look but it's quite typical of a
Dutch barn conversion and I think before
we go on I think that we will clarify
the conditions prior to prior to the
starting and yeah so under under
delegated under delegated powers right I
think we've debated this one quite well
we'll go to the vote we've had a
proposal and seconder all those in favor
to grant application you're not in this
chair committee resolves to grant
application I've got the wrong
application number sub 18 / 0 0 999 ful
thank you and we'll move on to our final
application of the evening which is 18 /
0 0 6 5 4 ful we just were just fair
looks one second whilst people leave
that clomp case advanced acoustics no
matter in hand see there on to item 18
slash zero zero six five four ful the
public should not turn on the hill
construction of storage units and Dale
we can't be present in this thank you
yes thank you I don't know whether I
dare say this but I've been bought on as
a late substitute okay go on Cathy Vance
yeah we we have the applications here as
usual application site marked by the
black duct again as usual the
application site shown inside the red
line the application is seeking approval
for the erection of a b8 storage and
warehousing facility of approximately
181 square meters the application site
is located 500 miles to the east of the
built-up area boundary of Knapton 500
meters 500 meters 500 meters to the east
of the built at boundary of napkin on
the hill in open countryside the site is
accessed from the Shugborough the site
is jacent to an existing storage
warehouse facility as you can see here
to the south
outside the application site just here
mmm
excuse me is a large agricultural
building and the row of storage units as
well as a hard standing area used for
storage and tipping what are
particularly liked members to note here
is the position of the fence there which
is currently the western boundary of the
site nearest dwelling is located
approximately 170 meters to the
southwest down here this plan shows the
development will be adjacent to the
existing storage warehousing facility
but within an open parcel of land that's
the fence I showed you a moment ago
this is the area where the applications
where the buildings will be constructed
as you can see it's beyond the
constraints of the existing site we'll
come back to that again on this one this
is the current boundary you can see the
distance from the building the proposal
is to move the boundary that far into
the open countryside that far into the
open field to construct these new units
and to construct this parking the
application the application would
introduce six additional units with
twelve parking spaces they're shown on
the left here the overall development
would equate to 331 square meters or
additional land land taken into the site
from the open countryside the overall
size of the building is thirty point
three meters long six meters wide the
ridge height being 3.8 meters same as
the existing units on-site materials
proposed our vertical profiled metal
color coated plating in dark green
galvanized shuttered doors and the steel
personal access door this side just just
for clarity shows the proposed site is
in an open parcel of land as I've
described before here adjacent to the
existing storage warehouse facilities
but it's it's not currently developed in
any way the site the brownfield extent
of the site is defined by that line and
obviously around here and around there
that's all brownfield land this is green
field open countryside quick slide of
the entrance to the site on to shut the
road the proposal will use the same
access as existing and the sequence of
slides just to give you a feel for the
character of the site as it is at the
moment the proposed UNIX would be very
much in character post UNIX would be
located just beyond this palisade fence
here in that open countryside
in that green field looking back the
other way here is the palisade along
there so the eunuchs would be in this
land here and finally just to give you a
feel of the character of the surrounding
area the recommendation is chairman is
refusal for the reasons in your report
thank you thank you down with no
registered speakers we haven't got the
ward member so we'll go sorry you can't
speak you're not allowed to I'm sorry
and you didn't resident on them that is
they're always unfortunately I'm sorry
about that
catch the Brian support from the Parish
Council which is not very detailed in
the report anyway and they're not here
to speak
there's no representation from the ward
member that in these circumstances we
would normally it would normally be
delegated to the officers and I would
suggest I will propose that we go to the
officers recommendation and approve
refusal second catch the brain
she'll go to the vote counts the brow
and bones yes it was in disguise
positive on second so catch the Brian
proposed to catch the bonds seconded and
we'll go to the vote
all those in favor so committee resolves
to refuse application 1800 six five four
and I believe there are no urgent
business and I will close the meeting
thank you and you did that once I catch
the rain any bang the gavel wants
tonight